[Music]
serena pitt
i love you very much
william here
wow it looks really good
here's to new beginnings yes joel mobile
proposed to serena pitt during tuesday
night's bachelor in paradise finale but
rose lovers almost thought joe wouldn't
get down on one knee after his ex
kendall long made a surprise appearance
on the beach
again oh hey there
[Music]
now although both of kendall's
appearances on the show were shocking to
the couple joe and serena told the
bachelor happy hour podcast post finale
that they both knew nothing and no one
would come between their relationship
that last her coming down at the end i
thought was i just was like okay at this
point i don't really care what you have
to say
in like the nicest way possible like
this is just not um the time yeah
well i can imagine for something so big
as an engagement you have your mind made
up like that is set and
i would hope that nothing
major would happen to sway that so i
think you know you guys were both very
cordial and i think she just had to say
what you had to say but at the end of
the day you were
very still zoned in on what you were
there to do in that moment and that was
to
ask serena to spend the rest of your
life together as for what's next for the
newly engaged couple we might be seeing
chicago's grocery store joe spending
some time in serena's hometown of
toronto we have to figure out where
we're going to live together um right
away not right away but i have a lease
that's up in april
and we had talked about it so we are
either going to
possibly try new york together or
split time between chicago and toronto
um
for the time being that's what we're
going to do is split time for from
chicago and toronto
and but that's going to be our next big
step would be moving it together yeah
yeah i mean it's kind of just whatever
makes sense for us in a couple months
both personally and professionally so we
both love new york it's kind of a bit of
like a neutral space where we're both
making sacrifice to be there um but
toronto chicago are both great cities
too so you know we don't have kids at
the moment so it's pretty easy and with
our livestock lifestyles to travel back
and forth so we're like maybe we get a
place in chicago place in toronto and we
do fifty-fifty i know our families would
probably like that option but will
bachelor nation be hearing wedding bells
anytime soon well joe and serena aren't
in any rush to walk down the aisle we're
not rushing down the aisle but i mean
we definitely feel confident the fact
that we want to be together right yeah i
mean
enjoy this moment your lives are about
to change there's just something now
where
doing life as a couple you know because
you were on the show and bachelor nation
as a whole is just has such a big fan
base it's going to be a lot it's going
to be intense um so just really soak it
in and enjoy it these are the good days
to just take a breath
date live together and then marriage
will come down the line
you